Chicago had the worst air to breathe in
the United States and in the world by
some measures on Wednesday the windy
City's iconic Skyline over Lake Michigan
was barely visible beneath the haze even
as President Joe Biden arrived for a
pre-scheduled visit landing at O'Hare
Airport under an air quality warning
I've never seen it like this Smoky or
anything like even fog like I've never
seen it be this bad people in 16 states
were advised to avoid breathing the
Smoky air and outdoor events were
canceled in mass in Detroit the founder
of the air monitoring firm just air said
the smoke only exacerbated the city's
long-running problem with pollution many
communities face this way too often
right while this Wildfire smoke allows
unfortunately many people to fill this
burden this is a burden that far too
long communities have faced day in and
day out the smoke is traveling thousands
of kilometers from Canada were close to
500 wildfires are now burning in remote
areas half of them out of control
meanwhile further south a heat Dome is
baking a massive area from Texas to
Florida climate scientists say this is
all enabled by the Earth's warming
atmosphere one might ask themselves is
this normal is this the way summer
usually starts off and the answer is not
really I mean some of these events we
could expect every year but yes having
multiple events is creating a a
different type of start to the summer in
Washington DC the worst is yet to come
with smoke forecast to drift Eastward
toward here Philadelphia and New York in
the days to come and the reality is in
this part of the world Wildfire season
has only just begun
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington
well bill ulfeda is the executive
director of The Nature Conservancy he
blames climate change for the increasing
number of wildfires and resulting air
quality issues
well the cause is climate change uh the
Canadian forests are suffering from
drought the fires are starting earlier
they're bigger they're more intense The
Season's going to be longer at this
point they're about 500 fires burning
half of those are out of control and
unmanaged and this is going to be going
on all summer long so really what we've
got to do is stop climate change and
then of course what we need to do is
find alternatives to fossil fuels more
renewable energy public transit all the
things we can do to reduce the causes of
climate change because it's really that
heat and the drought that is driving
these catastrophic Fires at this point
right now it's the Midwest it's Chicago
it's Detroit it's Pittsburgh you know
earlier this month it was New York the
the air quality in New York the aqi the
air quality index was over 300. I mean
that's that's unprecedented it's
unimaginable and and the worrisome thing
is this is going to happen again and
again like we knew when this happened
three weeks ago it would probably happen
again in a matter of days or probably
weeks so the best thing people can do is
pay attention to the warnings that
government is giving you know if you can
get an app on your phone that gives you
air quality updates that's an important
thing to do when the air quality is bad
follow the instructions like
0 to 50 that's great when you start
getting over 100 air quality index it's
worrisome but what we're seeing in the
midwest right now is 200 and even in
some instances low 300s that's where you
really should stay indoors and protect
yourselves and if you can get an air
purifier like that's a step we can all
take to clean the air inside our homes
when basically we have shelter in place